my brother jack how are we doing this
morning um pretty good so i'm i'm
calling you because um
i'm having a an issue with i guess
conflict resolution
with my in-laws and um they come from a
very different
cultural background and have different
behavior
norms than than the family i grew up
with so i'd like to get your perspective
on it
very cool man well thanks for the trust
there so what what two cultures are we
bringing together here
so i'm a white midwestern um guy
uh moved to los angeles but you know
ray is very kind of straight ahead you
know be direct tell it like it is
and my wonderful wife and her family are
from korea they've lived here for 20
years
you know so they're integrated um into
american culture but they also carry
you know these these norms where they
don't directly approach conflict the
same way that i do
and they have found that the way that i
do it can be um
pretty abrasive there you go i love
pretty harsh yeah
hey so first off i want to just high
five you brother from nashville to los
angeles thank you for being a guy who
loves his wife enough
to try to go down the the
hospitality route instead of just being
an egotistical brash idiotic
husband i applaud you brother and it's
going to take more work
and it's going to take some compromise
on your part in some re-imagination
learning some new language but dude good
for you man
if more people were like you would have
less of the nonsense we've got these
days so good for you
all right so give me a scenario
where you want to learn how you can
better address the situation
sure so the most recent one uh was
um that they come over to our house a
lot um they
sometimes stay pretty late and it's you
know past the kids bedtime i've got
small we've got small kids
and i'd like to tell them that it's time
to go um but
if i say things like that then they get
offended and they don't want to come
back and visit
and then my wife says uh don't be that
direct with them
just just let me tell them instead but
to me i feel like
i need to step in when it's like you
know 9 9 30 at night and
it's pretty late for the kids so will
she not step in is she asking you
to do something that you've seen her
repeatedly not do or does she have
a way that she can do it more gracefully
that that
um lets her parents retain their dignity
and their cultural respect
and still gets the the meets everybody's
needs which is we gotta get those kids
to bed
all right well she can do it with with
grace but
it has to kind of be a pre-planned thing
it can't be
something in the moment um where you
know oh
gosh we look at the clock and we realize
oh my gosh it's nine o'clock right it
has to be something where
i talked with her ahead of time and say
okay you know they're coming over
great let's just tell them it's time to
you know go around eight o'clock
and so why why don't we just do that my
wife has actually brought that to my
life over the last few years and it has
been
incredible now when we've got people
coming over to the house
we just tell them hey we're wrapping up
tonight at 7 7 30.
we got to get the kids to bed and
everybody drops their shoulders they're
like okay cool
it's just a gift right now of course we
there's the
occasion when everybody runs past it
we're having some great conversation
everyone's laughing carrying on and
suddenly it's 9 30 or 10 that happens
right
but it's rare especially doesn't happen
with in-laws
so do you not like pre-planning or do
you really at the root
you don't like not being able to say
what you want to say in your own house
um well the latter's definitely part of
it um and that's there's probably an ego
thing there
and i think i like to be a planner but
i think it just takes me by surprise
when you know like when they come
and they don't just realize that it's
time to leave
you know when it's like nine o'clock
what happens if you just start getting
the kids ready for bed
um i kind of feel like that
even would cause a conflict too like
whoa what are you
doing with the kids like we're we're
hanging out um
you know i think that would even be
considered as like i'm not
playing nice with the family gotcha so
here's here's the easy this may be the
easiest call i've ever taken on this
show that's not true there was one a few
weeks ago that was super easy
um it's just this simple
you can choose to
default to hospitality and harmony in
your home which means
being submissive to
your in-laws culture to the way they
communicate with one another
the way that they can retain dignity and
respect in their
home and in their marriage or you can
say this is my freaking house i can do
whatever i want
that's your two choices if it's me i'm
gonna do
everything i can to be more respectful
which means in your situation
we're probably gonna have to plan we're
probably gonna have to be pretty
pretty dogmatic about saying hey we're
done at seven o'clock we gotta get those
kids in bed
and then we're gonna roll from there i
would also recommend
having a regular regular
tea time or coffee time or meal time
with your father-in-law
do you all just go hang out you two
okay do you have you ever done that oh
do we yeah um
yeah actually yes and we get along
really great yeah so that would be
that would be super fun for both of us
so have you ever asked him
to teach you about his culture have you
ever asked him to say
hey i'm so intrigued i love your
daughter i want to learn more about this
how do i say this or how does somebody
express this and give him an opportunity
just to be the teacher how does that go
it goes really well yeah yeah we get
along really well and i think
me he and i connect um better than i
connect with
like the um the women in his family
outside of my wife um i think just as
guys and just we have
sort of similar personalities so yeah i
think i think the door is always open
there to connect with him more very cool
i think that would be i'd go a long way
and one final question before i let you
go
when you say if you come in and say hey
it's nine o'clock guys i'm so sorry
i gotta get these kids to bed and you
grab the kids you tell them
to do the hugs and kisses make the
rounds and then we're gonna take them
off to bed
and somebody sounds like your
mother-in-law says
that's so offensive i'm never we're
never coming back here again
like this is embarrassing for us we've
overstayed our welcome now we feel
ashamed
and um we committed a hospitality
violation
and i'm embarrassed i'm not coming back
do they actually come back
it takes a few weeks um but they do and
and yeah but that conversation doesn't
happen in the moment
it happens like you know on group chat
afterwards
that i'm not on so i hear about it from
my wife but yeah so
i i kind of have to show you know show
that i'm sorry that
i hurt the feelings a little bit invite
them over more
and then you know usually in a few weeks
it usually gets better
gotcha and so yeah i think letting your
wife
be a the powerhouse grown woman that she
is and if she says i can contribute to
this communication
and help honor my parents that's awesome
and if you offline can begin to deepen
your relationship with your
father-in-law
if you could do it with your
mother-in-law if you just had regular
you know
coffee with your mother-in-law once a
month once every few weeks and slowly
all continue to learn and grow and
um love each other and then yeah you put
your ego in a drawer when you're dealing
with your in-laws
you be respectful and hospitable and you
just plan
again man those seem like really small
things to honor somebody those seem like
really small
things to to continue to create
family peace right
and then you are free to raise your kids
in combination with your wife as best
you all see fit
as best as you all see fit but honoring
your in-laws is such a gift
and i know it's that's not me bro
i know man i know people are listening
to this being like i wouldn't do that i
would tell them
well then you're an idiot and jack
you're a good human being man
good for you for trying to be hospitable
um man you've made my whole day better
brother and it started off not too great
today
but you have turned it around for me man
so i'm grateful for you